okay let's accept
um challenge from a finnish player
yukka from
1800
um we got ourselves a rule of this here
again
and this time i'm on the
i'm on the black side um
yeah d3 it's the line i've
played um quite a bit myself
give some extra options also takes away
some options as as
these opening lines often do
[Music]
and it turns into a sort of
quiet quiet game here in the style of
the
duke or piano um
yeah bishop g5 is interesting but only
if he follows
knight g6 with knight h4 here otherwise
i'd just get
h6 with with the tempo next which is
gonna
render bishop g5 pretty pointless seeing
as
um seeing as h6 is a move that i
probably would have wanted to play
anyway
um okay so we have an interesting
point here if i go bishop e5
you can't sorry bishop b7 it can take on
e5
we're just gonna render the position a
little bit dry
and also let him take on b6 slightly
weakening my pawn structure
i'm thinking maybe ed4 instead
um now i've cd4 obviously i cannot
take an on an e4 because of
bishop d5 forking the rook on a8 and the
knight on e4
but i can go bishop b7
and then he probably would have had to
play d5 in order to save
the um to save the
the pawn now after bishop d4 i go c5
f3 takes an f6 which i think he probably
will
um he has weakened
the square on uh
um
[Music]
he has weakened the square on uh
i have weakened the square on d5 and
marks have strong lights for bishops but
bishop but i think the um
the dark square bishop might be strong
after i go c4 and also i have
knight f4 later on which might be a
strong opportunity
um i i don't know i think here
after bishop e5 which is obviously a
mouse slip i don't know i don't think i
should win that way
so let's let's just give him
give him a second chance
um
yeah now after all i get get c4 and
i do get the knight f4 stuff that i was
hoping for
so i i i think this
is um still pretty good for me knight d
g3 seems like the best move here in
order to make queen g6
with um
um queen g6 with um
with um knight to d3
it is interesting to go queen g6 or bit
queen g5
i do think however that bish page 3 here
is a little bit much
th knight h3 king g2
then who knows so let's go queen g5
and have the knight to
f3 i will go h5 and we'll see what
happens
obviously now if uh knight f3 uh which
would be a very logical move
attacking the queen i can go
queen takes g3 exploiting the pin and
after move like king h1
um then h4 and knight f3 may not that
be that great for me uh but i can take
on d4
first there and um
i think that would work pretty pretty
well
queen of three is an excellent move
preparing h4 and knight to f5
um and i do have the feeling that i
should take on
on h3 now whether i should
take with the bishop or the knight i
don't know
um let's take with them
with the bishop i just have
some kind of intuitive feeling
that um did i just blend her
does he have h4 now
i would have gotten a number of pawns
for the
for the piece but um i think i may have
blundered there
i had a nice trick there if you'd gone
queen g4 i could have gone
th um well still there was fg so well it
doesn't matter
but the point is if queen g5 there was
knight h3 and then queen g5 winning them
winning the the pawn uh regaining the
queen
truth be told i didn't get much at all
from from this whole
operation other than i lost a lot of
time
and my position probably got a little
bit worse
so there you go i'm still fine though
um knight d5 i do get
either knight g5 with tempo or i think
probably better um
knight c5 then if obviously if e6 i got
fe6 attacking the queen
so we can't do that otherwise i will get
to
trade of one of his
um one of his um
his two central pawns he's he is playing
really really well now
now though um getting a little bit
worried
uh rook h4 was a major threat so i feel
like i had to do something about that
yeah queen g7
still should be reasonably
reasonably safe here
uh okay queen e3 i do think i can take
an e5 now
i'll be happy to to trade um
trade uh everything because my pawn
structure is better
i do also think that my knight is better
than his
bishop which is which is sort of
biting on on granite right now on g6 and
also the pawns that i have on
c4 b5 a6 restricting they're sticking
that guy
in a major way also the rook on h4 is
horribly misplaced now
um for um for for the ending
end game i actually think after
after rookie 8 rookie 8
he may actually lose the game on the
spot
um i mean the only
sort of save i can see is maybe b4
i do think knight d3 may win maybe
there's
d6 then yeah he should have he should
have fought on there were some
interesting lines there but i do think
eventually it would have been successful
obviously apart from the
milestone though that was that was an
excellent game from
my 1800 rated opponent